you
Kareem abdul-jabbar and your most recent
book writing's on the wall searching for
a new equality beyond black and white
you write it's as if we've invented the
most precise and beautiful watch ever
created then strapped it to the tail of
a wild jackal what are you talking about
well I'm talking about the fact that
most Americans don't appreciate the fact
that their vote means a lot and their
opinion means a lot so they have the
ability to have their voices heard and
acted upon in our great democracy but
they don't take advantage of it so we
have this really incredible democracy
that give us the average person's power
and the average person does not vote
it's I think it's a shame that of all
the developed democracies in the world
the United States is last in voter
participation that that really bothers
me because if we don't keep our eyes on
the prize and if we don't understand how
we have to constantly be monitoring
what's going on and taking the steps to
rectify any problems these problems are
going to multiply and we ended up like
we are now very divided and at each
other's throats that that should not be
the case but unless if people want to
participate in this democracy it's that
that's what's going to happen
you're calling for new arguments or new
ways to look at old arguments how some
well I'm calling for new arguments we
the founding fathers really understood
that they had their own biases and their
own idiosyncrasies and that maybe they
didn't get it all right so they gave us
a document the Constitution that allows
it to be amended and tweaked so that it
can deal with problems as they arise
that was I think the genius of what the
founding fathers did and at this point
in the life of our democracy the average
person is not not engaged and not
involved and if that happens we end up
with a mess like we have right now so in
your view is the cream not rising to the
crop-top
when it comes to politics I think
politicians I think people are asleep at
the wheel with regard to using their
vote they need to use their vote to
punish the politicians who ignore their
needs so many politicians are more
interested in getting reelected than
they are in dealing with the needs of
their constituents they get elected they
start asking for money from wealthy
people to get reelected and they forget
about the people that they're supposed
to be representing that's that's a real
problem and unless the people who are
suffering from that look from that lack
of attention unless they do something
about it by using their vote this is
going to continue one of the issues that
you address in writings on the wall
the education system
what would you like to see changed well
I'd like to see the money that is spent
on education actually go to employing
competent teachers and making a good
education accessible to all Americans
that has changed drastically our public
education system needs to work for
everybody and now it doesn't now we have
exclusive schools that are able to
produce elite students and then we have
other schools like in the inner cities
where it's just a joke the kids don't
get educated and they suffer for it we
have to change that we have to get
everybody involved we also have to get
parents involved have them participate
in the decisions that are made in our
school boards and everything and that
again requires them being involved and
caring and using they're both using
their vote for City Council's and people
who are going to be elected to the
school board all of these things are
very crucial to getting the result that
you want which is an excellent education
for all of our students you write that
there is much inequality in America but
the most destructive inequality is
economic
absolutely I think people who do not
have the opportunity to support their
families end up dealing with desperate
measures to support their families to
support themselves we have so many
people who can't afford to raise their
children the way that their children
need to be raised and they give up we
have a whole lot of abandonment of young
people because the system does not
accommodate their needs and we have to
change that one of the new arguments
Kareem abdul-jabbar that you put in your
book is an argument over the our world
we've all heard about the n-word that
you talk about race as the r1y well the
race is really a very artificial
construct from what we can understand
from what anthropologists and
sociologists tell us people look
differently because they evolved in
different physical circumstances people
who evolved under the bright sun at the
equator got darker skin and people who
were wrong away from the equator but
we're all Homo sapiens were all the same
species but just the
the non-essential physical differences
that we have seem to put people in a
situation where they think that they are
different from other people we're all
the same and in America we see how what
that means because all of us are able to
contribute to our democracy with our
intelligence and our hard work and to
equal degrees so we have to forget about
the whole idea of race and understand
that it's all about who you live with
you know the people in your community
that's that that's so much more
important than what you look like in
terms of your physiology your book is
semi autobiographical as well then you
write that you've been writing for 4050
years that's what's changed what's
gotten better I think the whole idea
that people are starting to see even
people who don't look like them they're
starting to understand that these are
your fellow Americans so in that sense
we are a part of the same group our
ancestors came from various different
places but we're all here now and this
is our country and we've got to do
everything we can to make it the
greatest place in the world
from your book I was called an N in high
school I was called an N when I played
at UCLA and I was called an N last week
by someone who didn't like an article I
I put that sentence in there to let
people know that racism is still an
issue is still a problem
the election of President Obama did not
eliminate the racism and the systemic
racism that we have to deal with here in
America a lot of our institutions are
operationally fragmented and there is
bias at the heart of a lot of different
institutions in America and we have to
understand that and try to eliminate
those that those problems when we can
cream abdul-jabbar are you a role model
whether I like it or not I am a role
model the fact that I was able to
achieve what I was able to achieve as an
athlete and hopefully as an author it
makes me a role model I'm a parent so I
have to be a role model all parents are
role models so I don't think that any of
us escapes that that birdie for some
it's a burden for this is a joy but we
all end up in that position
are you a national Roma well I guess
look I'll have to anything it can be a
good thing I have to make it a good
thing it's like it's up to me to decide
what I can do with it and how to use it
so I've been trying to use it in a
positive way
and you write that I have a complicated
relationship with the media I've used my
celebrity to take political positions
I think that I've tried these much
liberty in a way that enables me to say
things that need to be said and I'm glad
to see there are other athletes that are
getting in line with that one's Tamir
rice was killed so unnecessarily in
Cleveland LeBron James came out and said
something about it I think that that was
very important to me you know the fact
that LeBron despite his incredible
celebrity and achievement as an athlete
he was concerned about the killing of a
young person in his community that
should not have been killed that was
awesome I was happy to see it I'm glad
that the whole tradition of activism has
not died in our community there were a
couple of members of the Cleveland
Browns also who came out and said
something and some of the guys on the
police force seem to have an issue with
that these guys were parents and they
could see easily how their kid could
have been Tamir rice quite in under the
same circumstances so their concerns
were valid and they washed their
concerns and I'm happy they did that is
it controversial is it harmful to a
professional athlete to take a political
stance it can be harmful to put to a
professional athlete but I think you
have to take that risk if it be
is that important and that meaningful to
you it's worth taking away when did you
start writing nineties I started writing
when I was in grade school really I'm
still in touch with the nun that taught
me in the seventh and eighth grade and
she she wrote me and said that she
remembered they entered me into an essay
contest while I was in the eighth grade
because I was the best rider in my class
so you know it's something I've enjoyed
my whole life but books and
looking in research when it when did you
started to that research I enjoyed
research I enjoyed being a historian you
know just finding out what happened and
understanding how that affects what's
going to happen if we don't learn from
the mistakes that we've made we are
condemned to repeating it so knowing
what happened is conciliation for
anybody who wants to understand what's
going to happen you talk in writings on
the wall about your conversion to Islam
and what it's meant to you and what it's
meant to other people well I think my
conversion to Islam really was something
that was personal to me it was a
religious
a religious event in my life people have
tried to make it political but really
was a spiritual thing for me and I think
Islam has given me a moral anchor that
has enabled me to differentiate between
right and wrong and understand life in
those terms so you know my conversion to
Islam was something that was very
personal it ended up becoming political
but I didn't want it to be like that I
probably would have done it different if
if I had had a chance to go back I'd do
it a little bit differently because it
didn't I didn't necessarily have to be
so public with it but it was important
to me and it was a way for me to assert
my own identity as a black American and
not have to be portrayed as somebody who
was fitting
he's a stereotype that was not actually
me so it enabled me to define myself as
such it was very important to me where'd
you grow up I grew up in in Manhattan
New York City I was born and raised in
Harlem had a great time growing up in I
wouldn't have traded it for anything
would your parents - my dad was a police
officer my mom was a seamstress she did
alterations and made dresses and stuff
like that and you mentioned the Catholic
nun as a teacher you went to Catholic
schools I worked at captain school up
through high school and then what do you
feel in your book you talk about rules
following the rules of the nuns
following the rules of the coaches
following the rules of death well yeah
I've had a lot of coaching I've had to
understand discipline from a lot of
other people's vantage points so I'm
happy at this point in my life that I'm
following my own path
what are you doing these days these days
I'm writing I'm spending time with my
granddaughter I'm a new grandparent I
have a beautiful granddaughter and just
trying to take in what's that what's
happening in the world and what about
your charity mine I have a foundation my
foundation tries to get kids from the
inner city to understand what STEM
education is all about science
technology engineering and math so we
send them to camp for our 5 days and 4
nights and give them an opportunity to
be exposed to STEM education and that
that enables them to get an idea of
where all the good jobs is going to be
in the 21st century so I think it's a
it's a good thing to get kids to
understand what the possibilities are so
many kids especially in the inner cities
they all want to be Denzel Washington or
Beyonce or LeBron James they don't
understand that there are so many great
jobs out there that require them to be
well grounded in science technology
engineering or math so by giving them an
insight as to where the jobs are that's
the right time in their lives I think
that that makes it possible for them to
to take a good path toward achieving
their goals
this writing come easy to you writing I
think writing does come easy to me it's
it's something I enjoy it I I'm able to
organize my thoughts in a coherent way
and get them out there so yeah I think
the writing is something that if it's a
nice unnatural obligation for me I seem
to enjoy is it easier than being out in
the public at times it's easier than
being in the public because so you have
time to think things through and make
sure that everything is what it needs to
be so that your your message is coherent
you know if you can't have your thoughts
organized and present them in a minute
elegent and organized way people are
going to get what you're all about
Kareem abdul-jabbar you recently penned
an op-ed in support of Hillary Clinton
why well I'm supporting this is Clinton
because I think that she has the
thoughts and the concerns about the
lower classes and middle classes that
or have been ignored by so many
politicians and I think that you know
her focus on trying to make the
government and make the political system
work for the average person I think
that's very worthwhile and I support her
in it if somebody said to you I'm a
Donald Trump supporter do you come to an
immediate do you have an immediate
picture in your head of who they are I
know I don't I have an idea of who they
are so many people now are being
motivated by fear so you know the whole
idea of what mr. Trump says about
immigrants and everything trying to make
us afraid of Mexican immigrants or
Muslims I think it's is reprehensible
and certainly not an accurate portrait
of immigrants or Muslims or any of the
other issues that he claims to be so
knowledgeable about I think he is
really showing everybody how eager it is
it's unfortunate but that's what that
mean in writings on the wall you talk
about reaction and reacting from fear
how do you what's your prescription I
think the only way that we can get over
fear is through knowledge becoming
familiar with the issues that we seem to
be afraid of once you get an idea of
what is actually happening you can
figure out a solution that does not
involve building walls across the
Mexican border we can fix a lot of these
issues if we have an honest and rational
approach to it I don't think we're going
to solve anything by fear-mongering
and demonizing people that doesn't work
is it time in your view we talked to
Bill Ayers yesterday and is it time in
your view to try a brand new system well
I mentioned earlier the founding fathers
gave us the means to tweak the
Constitution and to make the adjustments
that need to be made as we move forward
because there are new issues and new
problems that the founding fathers did
not foresee so they gave us the means to
deal with it and we have to just use the
tools that we have so many people are
ignorant of the fact that we have these
tools and that that's a shame
[Music]
once we get that idea across to people I
think a lot of people will calm down and
do what they have to do to affect
meaningful trade one more issue you
brought up in writings on the wall
political correctness
oh is that term mean to you if political
correctness really just had to do with
trying to be polite to people I don't I
don't see it as a big problem just
trying to be respectful to other people
and not offend them by the way you
depict them and talk about them that's
just
trying to be gracious you know and
that's all it's about I don't think it's
a big political issue but some people
want to make a big deal of it it's a
real problem if somebody says I'm not
politically correct what does that mean
to you I think to me it means that maybe
they have some offensive things that
they want to say about people like the
kind of annoyed that they have to watch
what they say but you know being polite
is it's a social grace that a lot of us
could
some instruction where did this book
come from this book came from just how I
feel about what's going on in in my
country and it's my attempt at trying to
talk about some solutions that that
might work that's all it is and it's
your what fifth six book eleven eleven
you know Kareem abdul-jabbar writings on
the wall was the name of the book
searching for a new equality beyond
black and white it comes out August of
2016
you're watching book TV on c-span too